So the trick to understanding this quiz
is noticing that myfun has a formal
parameter named x,
and when we're inside myfun,
when we're inside the body, when control
has reached these statements,
we need x to refer to the actual
argument and not the outside value.
So when we get in here, myfun x = outside x.
This can't happen because we've passed in os lusiadas.
My Portuguese pronunciation needs work.
Imagine I'm pronouncing that correctly, and that's going
to shadow or replace the old value of x.
However, there's only 1 variable here, x.
So y never changes.
So we will print out myfun y = outside y.
Similarly, since we are passing in os lusiadas to myfun as x,
we can print out myfun x is os luciadas,
but there is never an assignment of y
to os luciadas so we'll never end up printing out this variant.
So again, the key concept, we can have
multiple values of x in different contexts.
Out here, x is outside x.
In here, x is the value of the actual argument, os lusiandas,
which we often--let's say
aggressively pronounce in English as
The Lusiads , a Portuguese epic poem in 1572,
entirely worth checking out.